gentleman president Trump's call with
Vladimir Putin hello it is Putin hey
laddie what job it was cool and here at
the g20 service cut the crap
what's the deal with Don jr. well we
have the same Dame so I've got say here
any journey I'm talking about releasing
those emails was he kicked in the head
by a mule no baby that can be arranged
I had a son like him one oh yeah he is
now a pair of blue jeans if you know
what I meant I don't know he sleeps with
the turning are you on the phone yes
okay but first I just realized I have a
lot more stuff to turn over so I gave
the New York Times all of my texts I
gave CNN my snapchat login and I opened
a joint checking account with Joe
Scarborough
I told you that to do stuff for the
bunkers to do stuff you should seriously
consider pushing him out of an airplane
one more thing does for Christ's sake
what dad oh the guy came to the door and
in an effort to be transparent I gave
him all of our hard drives got up that
was the delivery guy oh please get the
pizza no sorry
well the truth Donald it's like double
dip everything's taken care of
hashtag control daddy some people want
to talk to you on CNN dad owned a
conference then your old friend
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you